hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on foreigner again and
today is Monday it's ìiî day for ubisoft
and we have some interesting news to
talk about today about the new stuff
that was shown at e3 so it was always
like the VP do enjoy you guys subscriber
for new I covered the informational site
a foreigner that being the balance
changes to hero updates the Patrick's on
the leaks so if you want to be kept up
today with everything happening within
the world of foreigner and never miss
out or nothing deaf we stay subscribe to
the channel and with that let's get
started with today's video though first
up spectator mode is actually coming it
too for honor about goddamn time
spectator mode this was teased before
the conference if it started spectator
mode will be starting somewhere in 2019
and here's a little glimpse of what its
gonna look like it's way better than
anything we ever have because of course
we're gonna have a spectator mode so I'm
completely satisfied with this it is a
work in progress so it might be a little
bit buggy but I'm completely satisfied
of what's happening see I'm completely
excited for this spectator mode it's
been so long and we've never gotten one
something finally glad that it's out and
then for what they showed you three it's
a little bit disappointing but all they
really showed was the new event shadows
of the hito kiri and on the website it
says this the Vikings Knights samurai in
the Wulin a foreigner have a haunting
new way to do battle on ps4 Xbox one and
PC soul rush a new limited time mode
introduced it as part of the new
available shadows of the hito kiri event
pits teams of Heroes against each other
in a fight to collect the most Souls by
killing soldiers it's not simply a race
to kill the most soldiers however each
hero has their own stock of souls which
counts towards their team total and a
hero can lose souls if killed by an
opposing hero who then steals a portion
of their souls furthermore down players
will lose the remaining souls on revive
and the only way for their team to
salvage the remaining souls is to revive
the downed player securing souls is
crucial to victory both teams can
deposit their earn Souls and designated
points on the battlefield increasing
their team's score the first team to a
thousand points will will push the
opposing team into breaking and then
once they're defeated will win the game
named after the terrifying new hero the
hito kiri who joined the samurai faction
this season the otherworldly shadows of
the hito kiri event also introduces new
illustrious outfits inspired by death
gods as well as new effects an all-new
emo and more
there is one illustrious outfit
available for action and it costs about
twenty thousand steel per hero in the
store and the new email' costs about ten
thousand still as well now the
illustrious outfits nor the emote will
be available as lootable items but both
will be available as part of the heat so
carry bundles
as for when this hito kiri event starts
it actually starts right now it is it
was actually even available before
foreigner even started their conference
it's going to it's literally out right
now so you can go play and enjoy some of
the stuff and it's going to start from
now June 10th all the way up until June
27 so we have about 17 days to do it
which is a little bit more than two
weeks so definitely go grab all the
items while you can and there's also
going to be a lot more community
challenges which are going to give us
steal like get X like the whole
community has to reach like 2 million
executions as just an example and will
receive a new emblem and some steel for
that prize if we happen to make it but
this is a whole community thing we don't
have to fight over it we just all have
to participate and then as for the
special event loop players can acquire
these unique items during the event by
playing the following games in PV AI or
PvP and that is going to be the soul
burst game-mode breached Dominion
tribute skirmish elimination brawl and
duel but only in PvP for dual and all
ranked mode so you're gonna be getting
all of this stuff available and all the
new items available to you as quick as
you can so deftly go play any of the
game modes that you can and for those
specific items it's a new battle outfit
a new ornament a new Idol effect emote
effect and execution effect which of
course the idol emo and execution are
the same thing but just for the
different slots so it's an effect in
ornament and a battle outfit on top of
that each of the 24 heroes is going to
be getting to a new types of weapons
it's one new weapon set made of three
different parts of course and of these
weapons they may drop during any mode
and within scavenger crates as well as
at the end of the matches during the
event the weapons will not be available
in the bundle so you can't buy these you
have to grind these yourself the only
thing I have a problem with is that this
was the shortest III conference of
anything that happened at Ubisoft and
that's what bothers me
this could have easily have been shown
on a dev stream with way more time to
talk about what they could have shown us
the new weapons what the new minions
look like the new game mode in action
but all they did was a 5 to the 3 minute
trailer showing off what it was and I'm
actually slightly disappointed about
that they didn't even show us season 11
stuff they didn't even show us year 4 or
no sequel it was just straight up the
new event and I'm really disappointed
about that because like I said this
could have been shown on any of the Dead
streams of way more time and we could
have had all the info that I could have
talked about but now no one knows what
the weapon looks like until somebody
grinds and makes a video on it which I
might consider doing and I might also
consider making a video showing off what
the battle outfit
is the emote affect the other effects
and just all the stuff in general so
everybody knows cuz I think that's kind
of [ __ ] that they didn't even show
any of this to us they could have I mean
they have like a 10 to 15 minute time
frame to show all this they could have
just done a quick bye and just show it
off everything within a second and I
would have been fine with that but no
they didn't even tell us and that's kind
of what disappoints me the most about
this III conference like I said it's
really disappointing I thought that we
were it was all hyped up that we were
gonna have like some crazy stuff and
really the coolest thing about this is
of course we get the new event but it's
spectator mode personally to me is my
favorite and I wish that this could have
been a better III conference for for
honor either way let me know in the
comments below what you guys think in
the new event since is live maybe you've
played it by the time this video is up I
might have a video in the couple days
I'm gonna be showing you guys how to get
the all the loot the fastest as usual
and I'm sure I'll try to be putting a
video up basically trying to show off
what is in it the new battle outfit to
emote the effects all the weapons I'm
gonna try to get all the weapons that's
gonna be a pain in the ass but I'll try
to get everything that I can if I can I
do apologize guys it's gonna take a long
time to grind for me but yeah guys like
the V if you do enjoy subscribe for new
guys that cover the informational side a
foreigner that being the balance changes
the hero updates the Patchett's and the
leaks if you want to be kept up today
with everything happening within the
world of foreigner and never miss out on
an update if we stay subscribe the
channel
my Twitter and discord to be in the
description down below my two most is
your videos gonna be popping up on
screen after this is over as well and
with that guys take care enjoy the rest
of your day and enjoy the new in-game
event
[Music]
you